this news story today that's so
important for this National conversation
we're having comes from Elon Musk who
happens to agree
with me people ask me you know
um where are the aliens and I I think if
if anyone would know about aliens on
Earth I would probably be me I would
think yeah I'm like you know very
familiar with space stuff
um
and I've seen no evidence of aliens I'm
not saying that we are unique I'm simply
stating to the best of my knowledge that
there is no evidence for other uh
conscious life I I I I hope that there
is and I hope they're peaceful uh
obviously the two important
characteristics
um but um we're just saying we haven't
seen anything yet there's no evidence no
I love this because Elon is right if
anybody on Earth would know about aliens
it would be this guy